once you do type stuff up you you use
emacs yeah I use emacs obviously the
superior editor of course
you uh let me just ask the ridiculous
futuristic question because emacs has
been around forever do you think in 100
years
we will still have emacs and Vim
or like pick it pick a let's say 50 100
years yeah no I mean whenever you're
doing anything in Linux
you you're spending a lot of time
editing little config files and
scripts and stuff and uh you need to be
able to pop in and out of
of editing those things and it needs to
work
like even if the the windowing GUI is
dead and all you've got is like a
command line you to get out of that
problem you might need to to enter an
editor and uh and alter a file so I
think on that level
there will always have to be sort of uh
very simple well emacs isn't very simple
but you know what I mean there have to
be basic editors that you can use from
either the command line or a GUI
um just for administering systems
now how widespread they'll be
um
you know there's a certain amount of
what's the story of the
the there's the the American folk tale
of the the the guy who the hammer guy
who drives the railroad spikes John
Henry trying to keep up with the steam
hammer and eventually this the steam
Hammer wins because he can't drive the
spikes fast enough so there's there's a
sense in which
you know Microsoft like
who knows how much they've invested in
code you know Visual Studio to you know
or or apple with xcode so they've put
huge amounts of money into enhancing
their Ides
and emacs in theory can duplicate all of
those features
um by you know if you just have enough
Linux hackers writing emacs lisp macros
but you know it at some point
um it's going to be hard to to maintain
that
level of uh of to to keep up feature for
feature
the the interesting thing about emacs
just is lasted a long time yeah and I I
think you've talked about
there's a certain like there's certain
fads
uh certainly in a in the um
software engineering space
and it's interesting to think about
technologies that sort of last
for a very long time and just kind of
being in the
what is it how do they get by it's like
the the
uh the Cockroaches of software or yeah
the bacteria are software or something
the like this base thing that nobody
everybody's just became reliant on
uh and they just Outlast everything else
and slowly slowly adjust with the times
with a little bit of a delay with a
little bit of customization by
individuals kind of that
but they're always there in the shadows
yeah and they Outlast everybody else
and I wonder if that's that might be the
story for a lot of Technologies
especially in the software space yeah
shell scripts you know all that stuff
you you CA you can't run the modern
world without
a bunch of shell scripts you know
booting up machines and and and running
things so um
it's yeah
that is going to be a hard thing to to
replace and then tech for type setting
that you use you said
for when I want to print it out yeah I
just have some simple uh macros that I
use but then I have to um
the the publisher put their foot down
and they they want it in in word format
now so
um years ago I wrote some macros to
convert
and this time
what did I do copy paste No I um I use
sort of regular Expressions so I was to
do italics in uh you know you you put it
in curly brackets and you do backslash i
t and then you type what you want to
type and that's how you get italics and
Tech
so you can create a regular expression
that'll look for some text between curly
brackets preceded by backslash it and
then uh instead
convert that to italics and word will do
that
word if you go deep enough into its
search and replace
UI you can do regular Expressions is
just reg UPS yeah
it's funny that you did that yeah I mean
I'm sure there's tools that help you
with that kind of thing but but the task
is sufficiently
simple
to where you can do a much better job
than anyone anybody else that still can
yeah yeah so that's a fascinating
process it works fine for me yeah and it
keeps you from messing around with
formatting yeah like oh what if I put
this chapter heading you know in
you know a sans-serif font you know it's
a it's just classic wanking
um and so you the the
those options are closed off in what I'm
doing